في مواجهه بدء الحكومه الاسرائيليه
والائتلاف عمليه تشريع ما بدا يسمى
بالانقلاب على النظام القضائي في اسرائيل
من حيث اقرار بنود مثل السيطره على لجنه
القضاه من قبل الحكومه الاسرائيليه ومنع
المحكمه العليا من مناقشه او الغاء قوانين
اساس تقرر في الكنيست وذلك بقراءه اولى
تحتاج الى قراءتين كي تصبح قوانين نافذه
في مواجهه كل ذلك اعداد هائله من
الاسرائيليين وصلت الى القدس الغربيه
حاصرت مبنى الكنيست ومباني الحكومه في هذه
المنطقه عمليا وذلك في اطار الاحتجاج
الدائم على هذا الموضوع
واليوم مشكلتنا اليوم ان مجرمين دخلوا الى
الكنيست ولستم من يدعي ذلك واحد كان في
السجن وهو السيد درعي و يواجهوا ثلاث
مذكرات اتهام بالفساد يجب ان تحسم ان كان
مذنبا
جئنا للدفاع عن القانون في اسرائيل
والمحكمه وكل ما نشا هنا وخاصه عن وثيقه
الاستقلال التي تقودنا مبادئها حتى اليوم
ولن نسمح بالمساس بذلك
هناك من يقول في اسرائيل بان هذه
الاحتجاجات لم تعد متعلقه بالمعارضه
والائتلاف او اليسار او اليمين في اسرائيل
فقط بل ان معظم الاسرائيليين باتوا ضد
محاوله اضعاف النظام القضائي ما قد يؤثر
على مناحي كثيره في اسرائيل الاقتصاديه
والسياسيه وحتى تلك الامنيه بالاضافه الى
العلاقه ما بين اسرائيل والعالم وخاصه
الولايات المتحده زياد حلبي العربيه القدس
الغربيه